and then there's this guy
uh who i i love i just love watching him
play and what he does in the community
has made him the rams walter payton man
of the year
nominee last night he became the first
40-something
to play the tackle position in a
national football league game and the
rams came out with a must-have and they
got it in arizona last night for the
uh now nine and four los angeles rams on
the mercedes-benz vans phone line our
friend andrew whitworth how are you whit
how's it going how we doing rich man
glad to be on here with you i'm doing
great how does it i mean you know i
guess i feel how does it feel to be a 40
year old man
you turn 40 sunday then you play monday
now it's tuesday how does it feel andrew
you know it's nice to have a victory in
your 40s you know
get a w my first my first you know i
don't have many firsts these days so
my first win as a 40 year old in the nfl
feels pretty good i bet the sense of
accomplishment must be off the charts
though andrew i mean that's a hell of an
accomplishment no question it is you
know as i've told people you know this
is more one it's not about the great
times it's more about the bad it's it's
uh you know to play this long and play
at this age you've uh you've had to
fight through injuries and time and and
things of just not feeling good and
maybe setbacks or
times when you've struggled and you've
had to uh overcome and kind of stay the
course and so it's one of those things
that uh just a sense of pride and joy to
you know push yourself to through
something you didn't think was really
possible and then now you're here and so
it's uh definitely something that my
family and all of us and
uh very proud of i mean there's a
photograph we're showing up on the
screen right now andrew from your
instagram account at andrew whitworth 77
of you coming off the field and you're
flanked by to your left your quarterback
matthew stafford to your right cooper
cup who's got a phone in his hand are
you facetiming someone right there what
was that what was that that was for the
nfl they do uh you know let guys kind of
film a little segment as they walk off
the field so they always coop
coop is the go-to for that so he usually
tries to find somebody else to get them
on the screen and uh he had walked up to
try and get me to say something so
we were having some good fun on the
facetime for the nfl okay so that's what
you were doing and then uh there was
another photograph
of you and what appears to be your
family did you a job uh did you adopt
jay glaser what's his head doing in the
middle of that photograph
you know what's going on
he let the wife and kids stay at his
place uh because they flew over for the
game
so they stayed there the night before
and uh stayed at his his home there and
uh they had a big time so they were
happy happy to be there happy to be
around uncle jay that's so cool look at
that never give up daddy what what does
that mean to you
on that front office well it means a lot
it's something the kids talk about all
the time um you know the ability to
choose to keep moving forward and never
giving up and
uh always persevering for what it is
that you want to do no matter what you
do in life man just them that attitude
of
uh keep pursuing your dreams and keep
pursuing a better version of yourself
every day and so
we talk about that a lot and i thought
it was cool that their mom gave him a
chance to write whatever they wanted
down and that was what the kids chose
yeah it's funny my mind if given that
opportunity he would hold up i want an
iphone that's what he would hold up
right now
you know
it's probably that's true too you know
never give up
that'd be my response to him so but
that's so cool so last night uh andrew
or la walk me through what the day was
like when you found out that
uh many of your colleagues had tested
positive for covet 19 uh including
ramsey and it was wild i mean to go into
the weekend uh we kind of knew uh that
we had one positive really kind of going
in
uh coming into the weekend on saturday
and then to realize that a couple
starters started falling out
you know day before the game
and then the day of the game um you know
it's one of those things that i said i i
think it was one of those things you
kind of needed as a team it put you in a
true
back against the wall everybody just
fight mentality
and that's how we responded i think it
gave us a great opportunity as a team to
just
truly just say say hey you know what all
the pressure's off now we're expected to
not be able to go win on the road on
monday night football after losing some
really key starters and to go out and
perform the way we did i think it's
something our team can build off of and
a confidence that can help us moving
forward yeah and you know the game kind
of turned early on because donald you
know put a spin move on
um on right on the quarterback right on
kyler murray in the tip ball for an
interception it's and then you guys go
down the field and score a touchdown
that that had to have was that in your
estimation the turning point of the game
last year i think really just the energy
we came out with to start the game and
and ability like guy like aaron that he
has to just take over a game when he
wants and i think he did a great job of
setting the tone for us for the day and
i mean really from that first snap on uh
i think that uh you know our team
knew that it was gonna be that kind of
day and and uh that's what we wanted and
so it ended up working in our favor the
energy and passion we came out with
and just uh backs against the wall
perform and we did it what's it like in
the huddle when uh when stafford and uh
cup are cooking like that
man it's a lot of fun i mean you know to
get odell up and going too and van
jefferson to play a big part i mean
getting all those guys confidence and
that's what we said when odell came in
and robert woods got hurt is that you
know it's going to take some weeks to
just get confidence and get everybody to
kind of plan new positions and bands
moving around
you know you got cup who's been just a
tremendous all year and i think that
you're starting to see it you're
starting to see guys develop some
confidence and continuity and and uh you
know i i don't think we could be happier
with the guys that are in our huddle
right now and and really the response
that we've gotten from from odell and
fan from everybody
i think it's been great and uh i liked
it i like the direction our team's
moving we just got to keep working boys
you know and obviously this is not your
first rodeo in the nfl and certainly
with the rams but what what sony
michelle is doing for me right now uh
looking at your team it reminds me of
the way things kind of work when
everything works well for your offense
that it's a run oriented offense that
when you and the rest your colleagues
are firing out and getting physical and
that was the conversation about your
three-game losing streak is that is that
other teams were being more physical
against you than you were against them
it strikes me you know like cj anderson
in the run towards the end of that year
with gurley and then anderson it just
strikes me he gives you that sony andrew
he definitely does i mean he has been uh
somebody that a lot of guys have been
excited about having him huddle and the
way he's running the football just
really the attitude and the power and
physicality he runs it with and i
definitely agree with you he reminds me
a lot of what we got from cj anderson um
you know that that year in 18 and uh
almost an identical style of runner and
it's definitely brought something to
every kind of run not just the ones
where you're piling them all in there
but even the gun and stuff like that he
brings such a physicality he's gonna
make guys tackle and uh that that puts a
lot of stress on the defense when you
got those things where you can run the
football put some physicality in the
game and then also throw it over their
head
um those are the kind of mary that we
really need that's the marriage we're
looking for and so he's brought that to
us and it's been great and not only that
but his presence you can tell being a
patriot being in some big games uh he
has a great demeanor out there and last
night was one of those guys just
constantly in the huddle being positive
and keeping a common force on us uh he's
been great to have so you don't hold it
against him that he scored the lone
touchdown of that super bowl against you
right you don't you know rich i'm almost
over it i'm moving
i'm sorry to bring it up and i'll dap
him up when he makes a good run but not
most
you know we had stafford on last week
too andrew whitworth he said he's
feeling good he didn't want to he said
that he didn't understand where all that
stuff came from and
boy i mean that throw to van jefferson
last night and i don't know if you saw
as well van given the the the game ball
that he caught um
the the ball that he caught to his dad
who is you know as the receiver coach on
the other side it was just it's quite a
moment you know all of it the the the
throw and then the moment after the game
i don't know if you're aware of any of
that andrew yeah definitely uh van um
is a passionate guy and somebody that
i've enjoyed getting to know and and
that kind of relationship with dads we
were talking about that last night just
uh it's got to be really really
different to me facing your dad such a
big moment in a game and probably i'm
sure really conflicting for him as well
i mean being a coach and then also your
son making big plays for the other team
but what a special deal that is and then
relationship they have and couldn't be
happier for van he's a guy's got a great
heart and then again a young player it's
going to be really good in this league
for a long time well i just kind of get
the sense uh and then we'll i just want
to talk about your your nomination for
for the for the big enchilada the walter
payton man in the year award um it just
seems that you guys uh might have you
know put your foot in the ground and
turn things around from that three-game
losing streak and and that this is the
rams team that we're going to see the
rest of the way and potentially you know
do what the bucks did last year which is
play for the whole shooting match in
your own home stadium what do you say to
that andrew whitworth what do you say i
say that's i say that's the goal and i
say that's how we feel i mean i think
we've uh found a little little bit of a
niche of who we think we are and what we
think we can do week in and week out and
we're confident and uh there's almost a
new passion to our team right now i
think it was a you know one of those
things that unfortunate to go through
but uh really good for us to go through
that three-game streak and realize some
things that we need to do better and be
more focused on and i think our team's
really excited and really confident we
got a lot of belief in each other
okay so let's talk about um your your
nomination congratulations uh on on that
and i give you the floor on what you're
up to here locally in los angeles in
your community about your walter payton
man of the year award nomination work
that you uh that you have earned
andrew
yeah i mean rich you know it's one of
those things it's always a humbling
honor and something that you look across
the league man just it's awesome to see
in our sport
how many guys are out there in the
community doing amazing things and and
uh it inspires you to pick it up and
inspires you to to do more yourself and
so i couldn't be more humbled and
honored to be a part of that group and
then you know for us here in la it's
it's really man it's nothing special
it's nothing that we're promoting it's
about
you know finding ways that we can be
there for people in the community in any
way possible and you know just meeting
people where they are and seeing if we
can be a positive step or hand or do
whatever we can to help them get to
where it is they're trying to get going
if it involves homelessness it involves
our bets
um you know really anything and medical
care for children all those things we've
been a part of over our time here i mean
one of the most humbling things i got to
do was when i got presented the award
they actually put me on a screen with
the 39 different charities and places
that we've affected over our thoughts
this year and videos from every one of
those charities it's uh it was really
special and it's something we're really
proud of and we're proud our kids get to
be a part of it too and
you know for us today we've got a unique
opportunity where we're going to get to
go uh give away a home fully furnished
to a family and wow it's just something
to us it means the world to just be
there for other people make life more
than just about yourself and uh that's
what we try to do and uh it just every
year we've been here it's just grown and
grown so you're going to hand the keys
to a fully furnished home to somebody
today do they know that this is
happening do they know this they don't
know yet but they will soon
wow
so you're going to surprise a family
with a new home fairly fully furnished
that's happening today in los angeles
it's happening today we've uh a couple
weeks ago we were able to help with some
families down payments on some new
houses and and then uh now this week so
i did a pledge rich this year that i
would uh give twenty thousand dollars
uh to try and help affect the homeless
situation in l.a uh every week of the
season that we had a home game and so
this is a part of that we're collecting
that money and every every couple weeks
we're trying to find something different
to do in the community and so this is a
part of it and uh man we're excited
about it yeah man andrew whitworth you
truly are well look man um thanks for
calling in after that big win and you
know also i just um
wanted to uh have somebody from
louisiana uh who is an lsu guy calling
to the show to make it let everyone know
what somebody from louisiana sounds like
um
so yeah
because you know we need that apparently
we need that rich we uh we have some
faulty microphones i think down there
what is
what do you mean there's a microphone
that makes somebody who's from
massachusetts and spent 30 years
coaching in the midwest sound like
they're from louisiana is that what
you're saying they're such a microphone
at lsu it's like one of those uh toners
you know i mean t-pain uh we get working
with some little
music there you know i don't know what's
going on but uh apparently there's a
little verb in there that makes you say
family
i'm not sure what it is
yeah i i don't i i i don't know what are
you excited about brian kelly being down
there now coach your team you know i
don't know him well but i yeah i mean i
think that a lot of people i've talked
to are excited about it and um
you know i uh look forward to getting a
chance to talk to him okay i think
tigertown you know what there's a plenty
of talent down there and probably the
most talented who have ever coached
uh down there at lsu that's for sure
because they're full of it so hopefully
we can get things going again part of
the lsu family right that's what he is
now that's right the family that's how
you say
family that's what it sounds like right
that's it well congrats to you on yours
uh you're right
and thanks for the call andrew you're
the man appreciate it i appreciate it
rich have a great day for you too that's
andrew whitworth getting ready to give
away a fully furnished home
to an unsuspecting family
family after
beating the cardinals on monday night
football
with his family
it's ram's family
as a 40 year old
dude what a story in the nfl what a
great story in the nfl andrew whitworth
good people walter payton manny your
nominee
love it hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here